what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty cool spider-man no way home news
news coming from tom holland himself
news coming from some insiders and a
plot leak that might tell us exactly how
sony and marvel studios plan to tease
toby mcguire and andrew garfield
spider-man in that first official not
teaser but official trailer that we've
all been waiting for and i've got to say
out of all the ways that sony and marvel
could tease toby and andrew being in the
film i actually like this way the best
and i'm gonna break down everything you
need to know of course in this video but
first if you would like a chance to win
this spider-man figurine be sure to
subscribe to my channel and to cosmic
culture and leave some comments on the
recent videos for your chance to win so
let's start off by talking about how
toby and andrew if they are indeed in
the movie which most of us believe they
are especially after you know some of
the leaks that we've gotten in the past
couple of days how they'll be teased in
the official spider-man no way home full
trailer we're gonna talk about this and
talk about a possible major death in
spider-man knowing home that tom holland
has hinted at in a recent interview but
we'll start with this leaked description
of what to possibly expect from the
official trailer if this is indeed true
it says in the full trailer we should
expect to see strange explaining the
spell a bit better peter says that his
identity being revealed is affecting
everyone around him and he has no other
choice it says we'll see somebody
throwing green paint at peter which is
something that i actually reported on on
my website it says there's a single shot
of peter at what looks like a courtroom
dr strange says that they shouldn't have
messed with the spell we see a shot of
peter talking to someone at a cafeteria
but it doesn't show who the person is
now this is most likely at feast and
this person could be aunt may but it
also could possibly be a hint at miles
morales since he's known to volunteer at
feast but that's something we'll have to
wait and see about it says we see the
lizard behind a magical barrier peter
stares at him with a scared look he has
pants but it's the same design from the
amazing spider-man sandman is shown as a
big sand monster we will see a fight
with electro at night peter has the
black and gold suit elektro has a yellow
and green gas station suit with yellow
electricity shining on part of his skin
we see willem defoe's goblin explaining
to peter that if strange sends them back
to their worlds they would die and he
has to help them we only see his face
and he's wearing a purple scarf we see
some of the bridge scene and peter
parker saving some people from the
bridge and here's where it gets intense
it says that the trailer ends with
somebody saying that peter will need
help cut to a black screen and then it
shows two shadows walking into the
sanctum we only see the shadows on the
ground then a shot of peter with a
confused look the music that plays is a
mix of toby and andrew's soundtracks and
oh my gosh if this is true if this
actually happens this alone is enough to
completely shatter the internet and make
everybody go insane
and in my opinion this is the perfect
way to tease them don't show them in the
trailer don't show them in their suits
don't show them not in their suits just
tease them just let everybody know hey
yeah they're coming back that way
everybody gets stupid excited for this
movie more than we already are but
nothing is really spoiled the big money
shot isn't spoiled i really like this i
really really like this tease them play
some of their music show the shadows but
don't show them but what do you think
about this do you want to see them or do
you just want them to be teased or do
you not want anything at all just to
walk into the movie blindly and
hopefully see them on screen let me know
right now what you think and now let's
talk about what tom holland spider-man
himself had to say in a recent interview
with total film where they actually did
release another new image for spider-man
no way home now in case you haven't seen
the image here it is right here i also
did post it to instagram and twitter so
if you're not following me you should be
but guess what it's another photo of the
bridge scene and we can see the back of
doc ock and spider-man on top of a car
on the bridge seemingly pointing at doc
ock or at least his arms his tentacle
arms either that or there could be
something behind doc gawk because it
doesn't seem like he's pointing exactly
at him it looks like he's pointing a
little bit to the right of him so this
could be somebody like the green goblin
coming in on his glider in the
background i would say that maybe it
could be another one of the spider-man
but i don't think they're going to be
coming in this scene but what we've been
shown in the trailer is that it'll be
doc ock and the green goblin on this
bridge because we've seen the green
goblin's pumpkin bomb rolling on the
bridge so i'm assuming spider-man is
either pointing to his tentacles or he's
pointing to the green goblin now like i
said this released with total film and
an interview they did with tom holland
in which he said some pretty exciting
and very interesting things about the
film while sitting down with total film
tom holland revealed that spider-man
know a home is going to be a big
surprise for fans but not in a way that
you may think he actually said that the
film is not going to be fun it's going
to be dark and it's going to be sad this
is what he had to say in the interview
what people will be really surprised
about is that it's not fun this film
it's dark and it's sad and it's going to
be really affecting you're going to see
characters that you love go through
things that you would never wish for
them to go through and i was just really
excited to kind of lean into that side
of peter parker now right away this
makes me think deaths deaths are coming
in this film now while he's saying this
he kind of made us believe that maybe
some other characters are going through
a lot of stuff but at the very end he
said he leaned into that side of peter
parker so it's probably peter spider-man
going through these things that tom
holland just mentioned and not another
character although i'm sure some
characters like mj and ned will also be
going through some stuff obviously but
the first thing i think of is a death
and there have been rumors that aunt may
could die and i've never really liked
this idea i don't like this idea at all
but tom holland is now saying that the
film's not fun it's dark and it's sad
and it's going to be really affecting
and you would never wish for these
characters to go through this aunt may
dying kind of fits that description
another theory on what this could
possibly be comes from another leak that
said perhaps at the end of the movie and
i should say spoilers if this does end
up being true it's just strictly a rumor
for now but there's one supposed plot
leak that says at the end of the movie
zendaya doesn't remember peter parker at
all and that would be pretty sad too
however i would say it would open the
door for gwen stacy to come in for those
of you who would like to see that happen
but it would still be pretty tragic and
it's also possible that perhaps happy
could die maybe ned could die based off
of what tom holland said i am assuming
that somebody important is going to die
in this film and to top this off daniel
rpk did say something similar to this on
twitter about spiderman no way home in a
tweet he said spiderman no way home will
do to holland's peter what i always
wanted make him suffer i don't hate
holland's peter or anything but that's
the whole point of the character he has
to suffer and lose everyone he loves
this deeply implies that somebody is
going to die and if i had to guess i'm
definitely going to say that it's
probably aunt mei mj happy or ned there
was a rumor that perhaps toby maguire
spider-man might die but i just i hate
that more than anything bring back toby
bring back andrew let everybody freak
out and then give him a happy ending
send them back to their universes in
peace because lately it seems pretty
clear that tom holland will be returning
for future spider-man films and a lot of
people want him to finally come out on
his own not relying on anybody and if
you take away some of these characters
from out of his life he'll definitely
have to do that as sad as it sounds but
that's just what i think what do you all
think please let me know in the comments
down below what you think about the
possibility of aunt may dying mj ned
happy or possibly another spider-man
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe for more if you want to stay
up to date you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you